le nord de la vallée de la bekaa au
liban et surtout évocateur de trois
choses la proximité avec la syrie les
débordements de la guerre civile
la présence musclée du hezbollah et la
culture du cannabis réception de leur
corps walid est cultivateur il a appris
à faire pousser la plante illégale de
son père qui l'avait appris lui de son
grand-père donc à l'horizon ça c'est
encore du cannabis tout ce qui est de
l'europe dans le rouge pour son fils
walid a cessé de faire pousser le
cannabis nous avons arrêté de le planter
dit-il site illégal vous êtes recherché
par les autorités
si vous êtes ma chanson vous arrêter
vous passez votre vie en prison
quoi bon de toute façon dit walid les
fermiers ne voit que très peu des
profits d'une industrie de plusieurs
centaines de millions de dollars dont 50
% de la production est exportée à
l'extérieur du liban cultivions juste
assez pour sur la mairie dit il ceux qui
profitent du cannabis ce sont les gros
trafiquants et les mafias qui peuvent
exporter une sorte de l'eau avec plus de
200 fermiers de son village et l'aide de
la france walid a lancé en 1999
la coopérative des coteaux d'héliopolis
et s'est mise à cultiver la vigne mais
déjà et des mollets
nous travaillons avec une matière noble
dit walid et ne sommes plus dans la mire
de l'état ne pouvons vivre en paix et la
tire pour les générations futures
c'est mieux pour le vieillissement pour
le moment les quelques 4000 tonnes de
raisins récoltés par la coopérative sont
surtout revendus aux grandes maisons
libanaise ancestrale mais walid et ses
partenaires rêve de rivaliser avec les
plus anciens comme le château ksara et
ouardi le couvent rouge a fait ses
débuts en 2010 et la coopérative a
produit 100 mille bouteilles cette année
c'est peu très peu sur les 8 millions de
bouteilles produites au liban mais après
des investissements de 5 millions de
dollars ici la coopérative se lance
maintenant à la conquête du marché
mondial
c'est le premier projet avec autant
budget dans cette région qui fait peur
aux gens ils provoquent langue city
quand ils entendent son nom notre
objectif c'est de permettre aux gens de
rester ici sur leurs terres pas de
devenir riche sans walid le fermi est
très fier de ce que walid devineront a
contribué à bâtir mais walid le
consommateur ne renie pas complètement
la culture du passé à preuve
demandez lui ce qu'il préfère encore
aujourd'hui de cannabis
encore une cavalière à lire ici du
cannabis fut magnifique ici marie ève
bédard radio-canada dans la vallée de la
bekaa au liban